when i was at espn i was 26 years old i
was just starting out doing sportscenter
and i had dreams of calling baseball
games
and part of the reason why i did that is
baseball is my first love i'm an nfl
network guy
uh now but you know baseball's my first
love
and grew up loving baseball and watching
the big red machine broke my heart
broke my heart in 1976 sweeping my
yankees
and um then suddenly here i am that was
1976 here it is now 1996
20 years later my dream job comes true
i'm on sportscenter
and all i wanted to do was call baseball
games and i had an opportunity to do so
and um i reached out to a colleague of
mine
for advice couldn't have been nicer gave
me every
literally spent 15 20 minutes on the
phone with me giving me advice on how to
call games and one of the reasons why i
reached out to him is he's an all-time
great
and then i got to work with him because
i was the first voice of studio voice of
espn radio
major league baseball on espn radio and
i watched this man work along with joe
morgan
one of the big red machiners who broke
my heart in 1976
and watching these two gentlemen
together call games for espn radio but
obviously
they were best known for their work on
sunday night baseball
was uh an honor an honor and a feather
in my cap that to this day
uh is still one never will forget it in
my career
so when joe morgan passed away this week
he's been on this show and
i think you re you tweeted out that
interview earlier this week right yes i
did
i did when joe morgan passed away at the
age of 77 i thought of this man and
asked him to come on the show
and uh he's kind enough to do so the
great john miller here on the rich eisen
show how are you john
i'm well uh rich and it was such
sad news about joe because
as you know joe seemingly had a a
an endless well of energy
nobody has had more energy than joe when
we were doing sunday night baseball
he was always flying into town from
somewhere else he'd
been at somebody's charity event helping
them raise money for their charity or
somebody's a charity golf tournament or
he'd been in cincinnati uh
doing doing business with the things
that he was doing there
i mean joe always had all these
different irons in the fire
and but a lot of them were about uh
raising money for his own charity for
kids
uh his the college scholarship uh that
that he had set up or scholarships for
kids who should be going to college but
who just didn't uh have the grades to
get a scholarship or maybe to
to afford going to college things like
that john he was always
uh working uh not just for himself but
for other people and and then he'd come
and do the games
and uh and so then to find out that he
had passed away
because when i had spoken with him and
we talked
two or three times during the summer you
know he was recuperating he'd had back
surgery
a year ago and he kept saying he was
getting better and better and
he could see the light at the end of the
tunnel and uh and that's as far as he
went with it and
then all of a sudden i wake up and i'm
getting messages that he's gone and it's
like i was
sort of in a state of disbelief joe
joe morgan uh hard to believe but
uh you know i i always remember the the
the thing about joe
i mean he was a fiery competitor as a
player
he was going to beat you and that was it
and he had that cocky bearing of a base
dealer
he was going to steal a base and you
couldn't stop him and he knew
that you couldn't stop him and and he
admitted at that time that he
you had to be cocky to be a a great base
dealer and
uh and he he knew exactly how good he
was
but at the same time people didn't see
the
the work and the the hours of dedication
that he put into it
we started working together and bill
james
the stats guru had come out with a book
somewhere in that
era around 1990 called the historical
baseball
abstract and he was talking about
all the different decades of baseball
and the way the game was
played at that time and the way it
changed from one decade to the next
but he also came up with formulas to
quantify
uh players and how good they were from
one era to a different era and he take
into account
uh the the way the game was played the
kind of ballpark the guy hid in things
like that
so when he gave his opinions about
the best players of all time the best
second baseman of all time
they weren't his opinions they were the
results of the formulas that he had
devised
to try to account for all those
variables so that you could
make a comparison between say joe morgan
in the modern era
and rogers hornsby from back in the 20s
and i told joe we were starting to work
together i said you know
in this book bill james made the case
that
you're the best second baseman of all
time
at your peak uh even over rogers hornsby
and joe says well that's ridiculous
how can how could i be better than a guy
who hit 424
with 42 home runs right uh nobody's been
better than that
at any position and so
as time went on he kind of saw every
three four years i'd bring that up again
and just to see if
maybe he was a little more amenable to
the possibility that maybe he was the
best of all time
which you'd think you maybe he'd argue
against hornsby right
and for himself there but he he he
couldn't see it but
i think the the great thing about joe
was that he knew how hard the game was
and to hit 424 he didn't care what era
you played in
that you had to be incredibly good he
says how many 400 hitters
were there that year again refreshed my
memory
and you know well it was just the one
and
uh yeah that's what i'm saying and 42
home runs in addition
so uh so that's that's who joe was and
uh so in that way he was humble and
he moved into the television booth and
you know he had the name you know him
since you were a kid because
he beat up on your yankees uh he was one
of the great
players of his era a two-time mvp who
won
what five consecutive gold glove awards
a perennial all-star
and every team he played on got better
because
he was on the team and so
his credentials were secure his name was
secure
to get a big network broadcasting job
but he started in cincinnati doing some
local tv
then with the giants because he lived in
the bay area right
and did the local giants games well i
got to tell you
learning his craft and he wanted to
know right can i be good at this
and and he figured as he was learning
how how it's done
and and and honing his craft then he
kind of came to feel like yeah i could
be good at this
and uh so the espn came calling uh and
that wasn't the only offer he had cbs
was coming in
to do the saturday afternoon games the
same year so there were two new
network uh affiliates coming in the same
year and they both
wanted him so he went with espn because
he thought
well it's prime time and we'll go to all
the ballparks and
so he he thought that was going to be
the better the more fun
uh opportunity so he took that and
um and i feel like uh he was a key
for you know he did that for 21 years we
were together for 21 years that is
amazing
and nobody knows better than you rich
that uh
you know this is not uh based on uh well
they were we were big red machine fans
and we were joe morgan fans
it's it's a business you don't last for
21 years
at that level because uh
you know they they just have a a nice
feeling about you
and it kind of says it all about how
good he was at it
that uh that he was there all that time
well you were you're a great team
together
john i i got to tell you you know um
my recollection you you didn't obviously
know at the time because you were
looking at the field
but i would sneak into the booth um when
when
when i was fortunate enough to be part
of the espn radio broadcasts and be at
the world series that you
you were calling with with joe i would
sneak into the booth
just to pick up some tips from you uh
watching you
and joe together and one thing that i
noticed that i picked up on and to be
honest that
i i started doing myself and now it's
become second nature
is when i uh broadcast i i talk
to the person that i'm uh you know who's
in the room with me
as if that's the person at home
listening to me
and i do that a lot and i do that on nfl
network i'm doing that literally right
now and i'm not even noticing it but
i do that because i watched you
when you would call the game and set
things up
you were talking to joe you you actually
moved your body
and talked to him and gestured with him
towards him and he would do the same to
you i i was like watching two friends
talk but you were broadcasting a game i
saw that with my own two eyes john
cool well i i appreciate that and it was
amazing you know
the funny thing was all these years
since i think 2010 was the last year we
did the
espn games together all the years
since then we would talk periodically
on the phone and uh you know
occasionally get together but uh
mainly on the phone and these phone
calls would go on for
two hours two and a half hours it's
amazing and we were still
talking to each other well the red sox
and yankees are probably the best
the yankees and red sox are probably in
the bottom of the fourth by that point
in time two and a half hours into your
conversation
yeah you know you know i i uh
the other thing was he was a trailblazer
because
you know bill white i think was the
first african-american
play-by-play broadcaster in in baseball
and uh and and it was did a great job at
it
uh joe was the first african-american
baseball analyst on tel on network
television
and he did that for 21 years in prime
time
um so in that way
i think because you look at the the ford
seafrick award
that the hall of fame gives out uh
i don't i don't see any black
play-by-play or
color analysts on that list
to ever have won that award and i i feel
like joe
should already have won that award and
uh
and now it'd be kind of bittersweet if
he if he wins it
then he's no longer around to enjoy it
but uh
so that that's you know joe is a guy who
and and and he was he was fun and i
learned so much about the game
from him but uh you know you could argue
with him
and and he liked that he needs to be
challenged i was intimidated by that
i got caught into some of that too john
um you know i
uh when i first met him i was kind of
intimidated by him
um because he was opinionated
you know a guy who um reminds me of him
that i've worked with is marshall falk
in terms of all-time great always has
tons of irons in the fire
has tons of opinions will definitely go
back at you
and is also just a great person to get
to know and is
you know frequently the smartest guy in
the room and
uh he would he would let you know if you
said something i
i would make a you know a point you know
in a conversation with him and he would
basically tell me you're you know what
you're talking about
you know and and it would be kind of
difficult for me to to take that but
i didn't i could see just like he kind
of liked the back and forth
you know he kind of digged it john and
you know every city would go into
there'd be somebody
who'd want to stop by the booth before
the game to say hello uh
you know movie actors uh politicians
tv stars you know you name it the one i
always remember
kind of fondly was spike lee the the
great director
walked into the booth at fenway park
before a game and he had come out with a
movie
a few months before that i thought was a
great movie called
uh was i think it's called inside man
did you ever see that with
denzel washington i think clive owen the
british guy
and so great movie and there's a little
mystery to it and
tension and drama and whatnot and
so joe introduces me to spike lee i'd
never met him and
and i told him how much i enjoyed that
movie and then
and then joe starts grilling him about
how come you haven't
started that uh jackie robinson movie
yet
and and spike lee is very defensive he's
like well i can't get
the funding for it uh the people are not
uh stepping up and uh
and joe says well maybe you're not
trying hard enough maybe maybe i should
go with you the next time and
you talk to these people and i mean
you know like he's like as if spike lee
works for joe you know
let me tell you i know all about the
movie business and you're not trying
hard
whatever and so he goes through that
thing and spike these
you know kind of getting exasperated
trying to explain to them that
i tried these people i tried those
people and they just didn't come through
with the money
and uh what can you do you got to get
the money to make a project like that to
do it right
and nobody wants to do it more than me
says yeah yeah yeah and he says another
thing i liked your movie inside man or
whatever it was called says uh but you
made a mistake when uh when this
happened and that happened and
uh don't think i don't i didn't notice
that you know
what that's joe morgan right
that is such a great story john hey i i
wanted to have you on to tell all of
these and
and uh you're the perfect person to to
talk about
uh joe from uh the perspective of uh his
other career
i guess is a way to put it and um and uh
and and it also means a lot to me that i
kind of had a front row seat for
for a few of those years in the
beginning of my career and i'll never
forget it so i just wanted to have you
on to talk about it
well i really appreciate it and i
appreciate the opportunity to
just to talk about joe a little bit and
uh it is still sort of
unbelievable to me that that he's gone
but uh
certainly a very large legacy and and
one thing
uh that i'm happy about and anybody who
knew him i think would have to be happy
about it
we know he didn't get cheated out of
life he he lived
every moment to the fullest that's for
sure and uh
and and you know i just i was
i just couldn't believe the energy that
he had i i said
don't you ever think that joey you've
accomplished so much
that maybe every once in a while you
should just go on vacation a little more
often and
you don't have to take care of you don't
have to answer the commissioner's call
because the commissioner was always
calling him the
bud ceiling and then now rob manfred
they ran things by him they
and i i don't think he was paid you know
he wasn't one of those like joe jory or
frank robinson later on or
uh you know a former baseball guy who
worked for the commissioner
they were he was friends with them but
they wanted to to
to grill him a little bit and bounce
things off of him and
so he was an advisor the same at the
hall of fame in cooperstown and uh
and joe would do things for the other
hall of famers he'd he'd take the bullet
for something that they were all
complaining about uh
the the last one that you may recall was
joe wrote a letter
sort of an open letter that he thought
the guys who were implicated in these
steroid
scandals and whatnot should not get into
the hall of fame well he
he was what he didn't say was that all
the hall of famers were were sending him
letters and emails and
making phone calls to him uh saying if
that happens we're not going to the hall
of fame that'll be the end of the last
time i
go to cooperstown and so on and so forth
and so joe just thought well instead of
uh these great legends of the game uh
having to go out in public and say that
themselves the joe decided
that he would just put this out there on
their behalf
uh and he got a lot of flack over it you
know but uh
at the same time it was like i think
they missed the actual point that he was
trying to make
is that the hall of famers themselves
and uh so i mean joe
to me was just as big a legend as any of
those people but uh
and yet he was the the guy out there who
was
trying to do things to help them out so
a great a great man great american in
as we like to say hashtag i-m-h-o
in your humble opinion john miller you
got you got the uh
the john miller drop that we play all
the time uh whenever we are
all getting together do you got that
which one rich the uh
you got that one remember he was here oh
yeah yeah we got there you go did this
one squad goals
there you go all the time i never knew
that was him
i forgot about it you lived a lasting
legacy when you came in studio here
years ago john but uh yeah
yeah well uh rich it's always fun to go
on with
hashtag the goat and uh
i i really appreciate you calling thanks
the call john right back at you
really appreciate it you be well you and
your family that's john miller the great
john miller